so what do we do now
do we need to report it he's been
accused and we know about it it's not a
credible accusation
[Music]
although it worked perfectly as novel
when you adapt it into a series it
changes we've created show that has a
very strong aesthetic we exposed for the
outside world and made people
silhouetted dark stuck in their own
prison since we have Morton directing
all eight episodes it really has a
uniformity of directorial vision and it
feels incredibly cinematically save for
our costume designer whose challenge is
how do I make them feel as realistic as
possible they're saying he looks smug
and remorseless it's not even 15 years
old it's a murder mystery but it's all
about the characters how they experience
it one of her challenges was rather why
not create a parody of these people how
do I really do justice to them how could
this even happen I can't get my head
around it I don't know how many times to
be sitting behind the monitor and new
thoughts they actually got the perfect
daddy
Chris brings both strengths and a
vulnerability to the character which is
really hard that's it that's your
justification he's being a father and
Michelle is just so open and very honest
and between Jay and the other actors
everyone they're so fantastic remember
that in their eyes it isn't just Jacob
who's guilty
you all are these actors have that
ability not just to embody the
complexity of these characters but to
project out from the screen and to
connect with the viewer
it's sort of like doing a play it's you
know you have these kind of big long to
kind of scenes which were written so
brilliantly if you think about the
complexity of scripting eight hours
you're building a Swiss watch start from
the music
[Music]
there was a really cohesive team and it
all came from this place that were just
in love with the story in these
characters and that's very exciting to
me to see this world really developed in
a vivid and full and complete way it's
character driven intense thriller all
these twists and turns you just hold on
to it go on this ride you're ruining his
life you're going to destroy there is
more going on here than you're aware of
more than what tell me
you
[Music]
you